lo que quiero que intenten hacer está da
una lista arbitraria aquí tengo un
ejemplo particular de una lista
arbitraria escriban una función para
ordenar está lista tal vez podrían
definir esa función como mi ordenamiento
o con cualquier otro nombre y lo que
debe hacer esta función es que cuando la
llamen con una lista pueda reordenar esa
lista no quiero que genere una copia de
la lista sino que cuando llame a la
función por ejemplo con a y luego hagan
print y se vea una versión ordenada de a
o sea que a se refiere a la misma lista
pero ordenada así que ahora se vería así
1 2 3 5 7 8 y ustedes podrían decir
bueno es esta muy fácil hay una función
en python para eso pueden literalmente
escribir a apunto short y lo que hace es
ordenar la lista no crear una copia sino
que en la misma lista se crea una
versión ordenada bueno no quiero que
usen esa función así que vamos a poner
un tache aquí
lo que quiero es que traten de hacer su
mejor intento para escribir una función
de ordenamiento y en tanto más
profundicen en esto se van a dar cuenta
de que hay muchas maneras de hacer un
ordenamiento y un ordenamiento es una
oportunidad de pensar en qué tan buena
es una función en qué tan bueno es un
proceso o qué tan rápido o qué tan
eficiente es un proceso al hacer algo y
vamos a empezar a hablar de algoritmos
así que les dejo este desafío traten de
ordenar esto y en el siguiente vídeo
trataré de hacer un algoritmo que es
simplemente un proceso para hacer algo
escribir un algoritmo de lo que es una
forma intuitiva de hacer un ordenamiento
no es la manera más eficiente de hacer
un ordenamiento y luego trataré de hacer
mi mejor esfuerzo para escribir este
algoritmo como un programa de payton